My,
my main question is actually something
you said a couple of lectures ago.
It was something along the lines of a
family.
I'm sorry.
I'm like,
God,
that's the history of your family.
Kind of like the sins of your family,
something like that.
Yeah.
Do you,
uh,
you're facing it all the time?
Yup.
What's a.
can you expand on that more?
Well,
there's this idea in the old testament
that your sins might be visited onto
your family seven generations down.
Seems kind of harsh,
but you know,
when you're confronting maybe your
father's tyrannical.
Yeah.
But you know,
maybe his father beat the hell out of
him and maybe his father,
his father was a vicious alcoholic and
he just bloody well don't know how far
back that goes.
And,
and that means also you don't exactly
know what you're dealing with,
right?
To some degree you're dealing with your
father,
but only partly what you're dealing with
is the pathological paternal spirit,
something like that.
And it's better to think about that way
because it becomes an existential issue
at that point.
You know?
So you could say that while the father
has two components,
and I,
I mean this psychologically speaking,
there's the great father that's
beneficial in protective,
that organize the society and teaches
you how to speak and has produced all
these wonderful things,
and then there's the tyrannical
oppressive part of the father,
just like there's the terrible part of
mother nature that's destructive and the
benevolent part of Mother Nature that's
wonderful and productive and you're
stuck with that,
right?
You're stuck with having to mediate
between those opposing forces,
just like you're stuck with the
adversarial part of yourself in the
heroic part of yourself and it's up to
you to set those things.
Right.
Otherwise they propagate into the future
and it isn't.
It's a straightforward thing to say how
to set them.
Right.
There's quite a good movie about that.
Oh No,
I won't be Magnolia,
which I really love.
It's by Paul Anderson,
if I remember correctly.
I hope that's right.
It's a beautiful movie and it's about
this.
Part of it's about this kid whose father
is really pushing them to be a superstar
at a,
at a quistio.
Right?
He's a genius kid.
Hey,
and uh,
the kids studies,
this guy named Charles Sport,
you don't understand this movie if you
don't know this because you got to know
about Charles fort to understand
magnolia.
Charles for was this weird old guy who
got rich with an inheritance when he was
20 and spent the rest of his life in
libraries looking up impossible things
and documenting them.
Impossible things that couldn't happen
from a scientific perspective that we're
well attested to by multiple observers
and he produced this news paper called
the 14 times,
which still runs anyways in Magnolia.
Magnolia begins with this guy who falls
out of a building and then it's shot by
a woman who misses her husband with a
rifle as he falls and I think she's a.
she's charged murder and the street
names have something to do with the
death sentence fault.
And all of that happened,
and then in the movie there's a rain of
frogs and there are rains of frogs from
time to time.
Sometimes they're frozen,
sometimes their reins of fish.
Sometimes they're frozen.
It's like,
what the hell?
How does that happen?
Happens quite frequently as it turns out
there's a rain of frogs in the,
in the,
uh,
movie magnolia and this little kid see
what happened to him is that he's on
stage and he ends up peeing his pants
because of the pressure basically and
humiliates himself and then there's this
reign of frogs which she kind of takes
us a sign from God and then he goes to
his father even he's like eight years
old,
this kid and he says,
you have to stop doing this to me.
And He's dead serious about very careful
not being,
you know,
what would you call insubordinate?
Nothing like that.
He decides that that's coming to an end
right now.
And you have to make those decisions in
your family because otherwise things
propagate down the generations.
Right?
And every family is rife with
pathologies of one form or another.
And you can learn from that and refused
to push it forward.
And that's part of,
I think what you do when you,
when you,
when you
shoulder your existential burden,
because everyone is the beneficiary and
the victim of the tyrannical father,
just like everyone is the beneficiary.
And the victim of mother nature and of
themselves,
and so you lock horns without and
straightened it out one way or another
and you don't move it forward to the
next generation.
So.
And maybe you detach it a bit from your
parents too because God only knows what
combination of catastrophes culminated
in their particular forms of pathology.
So
good enough.